[Musique]
l'été 1998
a été l'un des plus chauds enregistrés en
amérique du nord
c'était aussi la première fois que le public
entendait parler d'
une nouvelle menace environnementale la terre est
plus chaude en 1988
qu'à n'importe quel moment dans l'histoire des
mesures instrumentales
en témoignage avant  le
scientifique du congrès nasa james hansen a
affirmé que l'effet de serre était
déjà en train de changer les
alarmes climatiques ont également retenti lors d'une
conférence internationale sur le climat à
toronto les décideurs politiques doivent maintenant en
tenir compte et prendre des mesures qu'ils
ont ignorées trop longtemps
nous avons atteint un seuil si nous franchissons
ce seuil,
nous ne pourrons peut-être pas revenir les
responsables du siège américain d'exxon
étaient
préoccupés quelques semaines après ce témoignage,
une note de service de l'entreprise circule qui expose
ce qui allait devenir la
stratégie d'entreprise de l'entreprise
pour les années à venir brûler des combustibles fossiles
qui libèrent des gaz à effet de serre comme
document  dit pourrait devenir l'un des
plus grands problèmes environnementaux des
années 1990
et le surprenant envoyé  rence qui dit
que l'entreprise devrait souligner
l'incertitude scientifique autour de la
question du réchauffement climatique
et le rôle que jouent les gaz à effet de serre
exxon savait il y a des décennies que ses produits
pourraient être une menace pour le climat
illustré
mais l'entreprise a continué à émettre des doutes
sur le réchauffement climatique
qu'ils ont engagé  dans une campagne intentionnelle
de tromperie,
ils ont menti une sorte de double langage dont l'
impact atteindrait tout le chemin jusqu'au canada
[Musique]
donc c'est là que je le garde mon vieux casque
et c'est la combinaison que je portais
souvenirs d'une époque passionnante pour ed
garvey
c'était en 1979 et il venait de terminer son
baccalauréat en ingénierie,
il s'est rapidement retrouvé à bord de l'essel
atlantic,
un excellent pétrolier qui a navigué dans le golfe
du mexique,
cela me rappelle une période vraiment amusante de ma
vie.
travailler là-bas,
faire toute cette conception de l'équipement
et faire la conception de la
mise en service de l'instrumentation en
prenant  ces nouvelles mesures de dioxyde de
carbone que personne n'avait jamais faites auparavant
[Musique]
surveiller les océans donc ça me rappelle de
très bons souvenirs
travailler pour exxon était un endroit formidable où
travailler et c'était très tourné vers l'avenir
leur société de recherche et d'ingénierie
était
parmi les meilleures  dans le monde
à l'époque où garvey dirigeait un projet qui
cherchait à comprendre le rôle que les océans
jouaient dans l'absorption du dioxyde de carbone
ou des gaz à effet de serre, un laboratoire a été installé
sur ce géant des océans, de sorte que l'exxon montre que
le quatrième
plus grand navire du monde était
essentiellement énorme  une île flottante
c'était quelque chose dans lequel une grande partie de
la société était impliquée
[Musique
] c'était une période chargée pour les scientifiques d'exxon
ils faisaient des recherches révolutionnaires
sur les énergies renouvelables,
y compris les panneaux solaires et les
batteries au lithium
ils travaillaient également sur des modèles climatiques
c'était  un problème défensif mais
ce n'était pas celui de cacher le problème c'était l'
un de
nous avons réalisé que cela allait être un
problème pour les fossi  l'industrie du carburant et
nous voulons que nos scientifiques soient des
contributeurs
parce que nous voulons que nos opinions soient entendues
à la table lorsque les discussions commencent
sur ce qu'il faut faire à ce sujet
[La musique]
est une
étude des plantes au début des années 1980, ce qui l'a
amenée à étudier la
science du climat
les biologistes se sont rendus dans les jungles
du panama pour étudier comment les plantes réagissaient à l'
augmentation du dioxyde de carbone dans l'
atmosphère d'
accord les
scientifiques d'exxon étaient à la
pointe de cette recherche
cette note envoyée aux chefs d'entreprise en
était l'un des documents mis au jour par des
journalistes d'investigation dans le  nous
ce graphique prédit avec une grande précision
l'augmentation des
concentrations de dioxyde de carbone atmosphérique et des températures
que nous voyons aujourd'hui
[Musique]
citant plusieurs experts, la note de service indique
que le réchauffement climatique pourrait avoir
des
impacts catastrophiques et au moment où ces impacts
sont mesurables,
ils pourraient être irréversibles pour
l'entreprise  essayait déjà de
mesurer ces effets
au canada
imperial oil limited huit oui  rs
filiale imperial oil également connue sous le nom d'
esso
est au canada depuis plus de 140 ans
les produits qu'il utilise pour entretenir votre voiture
elle était considérée comme la première marque
d'essence
au canada la société est un pionnier de l'exploration arctique
et elle a même construit des îles artificielles pour
extraire le pétrole
tout en  exxon sa société perroquet a insisté
sur l'incertitude du changement climatique la
science l'
impériale était plus préoccupée par les
impacts possibles du réchauffement climatique
dans l'arctique à la fin des années 1980
elle a commandé une étude pour voir si la
fonte du pergélisol
pourrait nuire à ses projets de pipeline dans la
vallée du fleuve mackenzie en  les territoires du nord-ouest
[musique]
l'entreprise a travaillé en étroite collaboration avec
environnement canada sur un
projet de recherche climatique révolutionnaire
stuart cohen était responsable de cette
étude la zone d'étude comprend le nord-est de
la Colombie-Britannique le nord de l'alberta le
nord-ouest de la saskatchewan et à peu
près toute la vallée du mackenzie jusqu'à
la mer de beaufort
il a déjà été identifié dans les années 1980
que le mckenzie  la région de la vallée se
déformait plus rapidement que toute autre partie
du pays,
ce qui suscitait l'intérêt pour cette
raison,
cohen et son équipe ont décidé de
s'associer à l'huile impériale, ils ont compris à
quel point il était important qu'ils voulaient faire
partie du projet,
ils ont apporté leur expertise, ils
ont apporté un soutien financier,
donc ils étaient assez sérieux à ce sujet et
j'ai beaucoup apprécié leur soutien,
la relation se passait très bien
probablement jusqu'à la fin de 1992 environ,
mais un jour, stewart a eu du mal à
joindre son contact à l'impériale
sans trop d'avertissement, ils ont abandonné
ce qui s'est passé  ils ont juste disparu quand
ils ont cessé de répondre à vos appels téléphoniques,
c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé exactement et
je pense que ce n'était
clairement pas le choix du
personnel technique avec lequel je travaillais,
ils ne voulaient pas faire ça, on leur a
dit désolé de devoir laisser tomber  hors de ce
projet,
mon contact principal là-bas m'a dit en privé
que oui, c'était un ordre exécutif
de ne plus s'engager sur
recherche sur le changement climatique
stuart cohen a vu une industrie en difficulté
qui était à la croisée des chemins
je pense que certaines personnes dans l'
industrie de l'énergie ont vu cela
comme un signe que leur industrie
serait menacée et qu'elles allaient devoir y
faire
face d'une manière ou d'une autre  et
malheureusement
ils ont fait un choix qui était de combattre
la
science c'est
[la musique]
lorsque sheila cops a été nommée ministre
de l'environnement en 1993
sa mission était claire de donner
suite aux engagements pris un an
plus tôt par le canada à rio
la communauté internationale s'est mobilisée  sur
le dossier du changement climatique
au début des années 1990 c'était une période chargée
qui a finalement culminé avec le sommet de la terre
à rio
pour continuer dans cette voie pourrait
mener à la
fin de notre civilisation
[musique]
les participants à la conférence ont adopté la
première convention-cadre
sur le changement climatique bien que  il n'y avait pas de
mesures contraignantes
[Musique]
pour tenir les promesses faites par le
précédent gouvernement malrone
à rio le pair libéral  Ty a fixé des objectifs ambitieux d'
ici 2005, le Canada allait réduire
les gaz à effet de serre de
20 % par rapport aux niveaux de 1988
[Musique],
mais avant de poursuivre l'histoire de Sheila Kopp,
il est crucial de comprendre ce qui se
passait dans l'industrie pétrolière américaine. Les
développements là-bas auraient un impact sur le Canada
dans les années 1990.  les compagnies pétrolières
s'organisaient les données scientifiques nous disent
qu'il n'y a pas de réchauffement climatique que nous
pouvons détecter
ce que les scientifiques débattent est de savoir
s'il pourrait y en avoir un futur
les scientifiques financés par l'industrie ont attaqué le
consensus émergent sur le changement climatique
et ils se sont opposés aux réglementations
s'il vous plaît  accueillir notre président
lee raymond avec l'arrivée de lee
raymond
le nouveau PDG d'exxon la rhétorique y est
devenue plus extrême
il a insisté sur le fait que nous ne savions toujours pas
si l'activité humaine
jouait un rôle dans le changement climatique de nombreux
facteurs, selon lui, pourraient en être la cause
si nous  s'il n'y avait pas ici le climat changerait
cela a à voir avec les taches solaires cela a à voir
avec l'oscillation de la terre
il y a toutes sortes de choses
qui vont et viennent,
le dossier scientifique même à la fin des années
70 et au début des années 80 était suffisant pour rejeter
cet argument
qui est juste un échec à comprendre la
science, je veux dire que c'est le déni
au début des années 90, l'approche des huiles impériales
était plus  plus nuancée que celle de sa société perroquet
imperial a souligné les risques économiques
d'éventuelles réglementations gouvernementales sur le
changement climatique,
mais elle a publiquement reconnu que le
changement climatique était réel
george greene a travaillé pour imperial oil dans
les années 1970,
il a ensuite travaillé sur
les questions environnementales pour le gouvernement fédéral
gouvernement
il y a dans le dossier en parallèle
une reconnaissance
de la science du climat au début des années 90
qu'il est
probablement réel que nous avons un réchauffement climatique et
qu'il aura probablement des impacts,
mais pendant le mandat de shilakops en tant que
ministre de l'environnement,
la position de l'impérial
s'alignerait progressivement sur  exons
malgré tout ce qu'il savait sur le
changement climatique, la position publique de l'entreprise
était d'environ  pour changer radicalement le
nombre d'entre nous a
vu ce que nous appellerions une exonisation progressive et
j'utiliserai un terme amusant
d'exonisation de l'entreprise non seulement en portant des
costumes gris, mais en fait dans des positions politiques,
exxon n'accepte pas que le
climat affecte son  Je pense que les affaires ont été
transférées de plus en plus au Canada
vers les opérations canadiennes. Un ancien
cadre supérieur d'
Imperial Oil ayant des liens étroits avec l'
industrie
nous a confirmé qu'à partir de 1995
, les politiques environnementales de l'entreprise
étaient largement dictées
par le siège social au Texas et que des
mots comme développement durable
étaient maintenant interdits, seul le premier ministre
[Music] a
rapidement découvert que les lobbyistes et les
principaux représentants de l'industrie, en
particulier l'huile impériale, jouaient un
rôle clé dans le groupe du vendredi
[Music]
la loterie,
ce groupe informel se rencontrait souvent et les
politiciens étaient
invités, mais selon les flics de Sheila, le
groupe du vendredi
a principalement servi de moyen pour l'industrie de
s'organiser
contre les réglementations environnementales. Les
flics ont également vu que l'industrie  essayer a été soutenu
par des parties du gouvernement, à
savoir le ministère des ressources naturelles,
ils avaient beaucoup plus d'influence
à la table du cabinet les flics de sheila et
environnement canada étaient isolés l'
une des plus grandes batailles des flics concernait l'
introduction de mesures volontaires
comme moyen d'amener les grandes industries à
réduire leur  les flics des émissions se sont
battus pour une réglementation stricte tandis
qu'industrie canada et le ministre des ressources naturelles
mclellan ont plaidé pour une approche volontaire,
nous n'atteindrons pas l'objectif si
nous le faisons, vous savez si nous nous mettons un pistolet sur la
tempe
et nous explosons la cervelle en termes de
fondements économiques de notre pays,
c'est à cette époque que l'Imperial Oil,
comme sa société mère américaine
Exxon, a commencé à remettre en question la science
entourant le changement climatique,
créant le doute et la confusion sur cette
question
dans les archives nationales du Canada. Nous avons
trouvé cette lettre de 1994
envoyée par le PDG de  impérial à plusieurs
ministres
[Musique]
l'incertitude scientifique entourant le
changement climatique, selon lui,
appelle à  la retenue gouvernementale trop d'
intervention
risquerait de créer des dommages sociaux et économiques
la question était de savoir comment réduire
les gaz à effet de serre
tout en protégeant l'économie et personne
ne travaillait sur ce que
nous essayions tous de tirer d'un côté
ou de l'autre avram lazar
travaillait comme senior  fonctionnaire d'
environnement canada dans les années 1990,
il était responsable du dossier des changements
climatiques j'étais un échec complet
sur les changements climatiques parce que l'industrie a
senti
que le gouvernement n'était pas prêt à agir
et ils avaient raison
nous n'avons pas encore agi selon les flics
un  l'une des raisons pour lesquelles le gouvernement a été si
lent à agir
était une énorme armée de lobbyistes de l'industrie
[Musique]
en 1995, l'industrie de la province de l'
alberta a
gagné le gouvernement a mis en place un
registre volontaire des
émissions sans objectifs précis ni délais
trois ans après son arrivée  à
environnement canada, sheila cops serait
mélangée
que l'affichage a été l'un des plus
difficiles de sa carrière
ouais je ne veux pas parler
[Musique]
[  Musique]
les efforts du gouvernement sur le terrain signifiaient que
près d'une décennie était perdue,
mais la vraie bataille était encore à venir
et l'
impérial adopterait une ligne sceptique de plus en plus
climale je suis d'accord avec les gens du
côté vert
mais je ne pense pas que ce soit illégitime
pour l'industrie  représenter ses intérêts
maintenant s'ils mentent
s'ils déforment les faits s'ils déforment les
faits c'est contraire à l'éthique et c'est politiquement
illégitime
dossier en tant que
ministre nouvellement nommé,
il s'est rendu à calgary en août 1999
pour rencontrer des représentants de l'
industrie pétrolière et gazière,
il s'attendait à une réunion sociale décontractée,
c'était une réunion pour vous connaître
bonjour, ce n'était pas
censé être un  discussion de fond sur des
questions scientifiques,
mais il a été surpris par l'attitude d'
un des participants
qui l'a immédiatement attaqué sur le
changement climatique.
disait simplement que la science est
fausse, nous le savons parce que nous avons les
scientifiques la capacité intellectuelle de
vous dire que c'est faux
il était si belliqueux lors de notre première
rencontre que j'avais vraiment peu d'
intérêt pour une autre rencontre avec lui
parce que
j'allais me faire frapper  autour de
la salle, l'homme qui frappait
était bob peterson alors PDG d'imperial
oil
après avoir gravi les échelons de l'entreprise
qu'il a pris en charge en 1992.
après son arrivée, d'anciens employés
nous ont dit qu'il y avait eu un durcissement et
une exonération de la position de l'entreprise
sur la question du climat  changement
nous avons plus que doublé l'activité commerciale des
entreprises du nord
nos objectifs d'emploi ont été largement
dépassés
robert peterson était l'un des plus
ardents promoteurs des sables bitumineux dans les
années 1970 et 1980
leur énorme potentiel est connu depuis longtemps
mais les nouvelles technologies les rendaient
moins chers à  exploiter
au début des années 2000 l'Imperial Oil
avec d'
autres compagnies investit des milliards de
dollars dans ce nouvel eldorado
et c'était une bonne nouvelle pour les actionnaires,
vous savez, je pense que c'est sophie tucker
qui a observé un jour
que j'étais riche et que j'étais pauvre et
riche, c'est mieux,
le problème était que malgré les
efforts de l'industrie pour rendre les sables bitumineux moins
polluants
un baril de  le pétrole de sables bitumineux était bien pire
pour le climat
qu'un baril de pétrole conventionnel
un fait qui s'opposait directement aux
objectifs de réduction des émissions de gaz à effet de serre du canada
les yeux du monde sont sur nous maintenant en
la communauté internationale s'est réunie à kyoto
pour lutter contre le changement climatique
les enjeux cette fois  étaient des pays élevés qui
espéraient négocier le premier
accord contraignant destiné à réduire
les gaz à effet de serre le
président clinton et je travaillerai dur dans
les coulisses
comme les autres pays qui ont signé le
canada avaient besoin d'élaborer un véritable plan pour
atteindre ses objectifs en matière de changement climatique
mr craity  mettez-moi dans l'environnement avec les
instructions pour
m'assurer que j'ai fait quelque chose pour obtenir
une ratification de l'accord de kyoto,
découvrez simplement ce que nous pouvons faire  maintenant,
c'est à ce moment-là que je suis allé faire
des tournées de conférences et d'autres choses pour obtenir du
soutien alors
que david anderson commençait à présenter le nouveau
plan climatique à
travers le pays, les opposants à l'accord
n'ont pas tardé à s'organiser
et l'un des critiques les plus implacables de kyoto
était bob peterson d'imperial oil
nous nous opposons à kyoto, nous pensons que c'est une
politique publique stupide qui est inappropriée,
irréalisable
et qui devrait vraiment être reconsidérée par le
gouvernement du canada, mais le patron d'Imperial Oil
irait encore plus loin, il a systématiquement
semé le doute sur la science qui
sous-tend le réchauffement climatique, comme il l'a fait lors de
sa première rencontre avec
le dioxyde de carbone du ministre anderson n'est pas un polluant mais un
ingrédient essentiel à la vie sur cette
planète, a-t-
il écrit dans le magazine de l'entreprise en
1998.
le lien qu'il dit entre la combustion de
combustibles fossiles et le changement climatique
reste une hypothèse non prouvée,
donc d'une certaine manière, il est allé à l'encontre  son
ancien poste politique de l'entreprise
euh il a lui-même remis en question la science sur le
climat et si  euh
l'activité humaine l'affectait ou
s'il s'agissait d'une variation naturelle, il
y avait donc un changement
et pour être honnête, je ne peux pas dire si
ce changement était son propre point de vue
et où il voulait que le pétrole impérial aille
ou s'il commençait maintenant
à avoir son exxon  empreinte au plus
fort des débats sur l'
accord de kyoto en 2002
imperial oil et d'autres sociétés ont financé
une conférence
de climato-sceptiques connus l'
accord de kyoto qu'ils ont dit
était unilatéral et basé sur des arguments non prouvés
la justification de kyoto est
non fondée et biaisée
il endommage le  l'économie et ne fait
aucun bien,
vous savez pourquoi le faire
fondamentalement,
ce que nous ne savions pas, c'est que pendant que l'
Impériale mettait publiquement en doute le
changement climatique en
interne, elle le prenait très au
sérieux
en 1996, l'Impériale faisait partie d'un
consortium
d'entreprises construisant le sable  projet
au large de la Nouvelle-Écosse,
ils ont ajusté la hauteur de cette
plate-forme pétrolière offshore pour tenir compte
de l'élévation du niveau de la mer
causée par le réchauffement climatique  g nous avons interrogé
l'huile impériale sur la zibeline
et sa position sur le changement climatique
au début des années 2000,
ils nous ont dit que leur position à l'
époque reflétait l'évolution du débat sur
la science du climat et les politiques
de réduction des émissions,
mais à l'époque, ce n'était pas seulement l'
huile impériale qui se battait  contre kyoto, une
grande partie de la classe d'affaires canadienne a fait
de même
et ils l'ont attaquée avec
des arguments nationalistes et économiques
en octobre 2002 un nouveau slogan une
solution faite au canada
a été proposée le pdg d'imperial oil a
été parmi les premiers à l'utiliser nous méritons
un canadien  approche qui produit
des résultats immédiats et investit dans notre
avenir environnemental
le slogan a été utilisé dans le cadre d'une
campagne agressive
lancée par plusieurs industries il
deviendrait bientôt populaire auprès de nombreux
politiciens approche faite au canada
un plan fait au canada une solution faite au canada il a créé
un  beaucoup de confusion mais c'était le
point
un sondage publié à l'époque montre que le
soutien à kyoto a baissé de
45 pour cent  des répondants disant que le
gouvernement devrait favoriser
une solution faite au canada au lieu de
kyoto
nous avions un très fort soutien à travers le
pays
et il a baissé plus tard à la suite de
la campagne de l'industrie
mais malgré l'opposition en décembre 2002
david anderson a vu ses efforts récompensés
après  sa bataille acharnée
qui est l'un des moments forts de mon temps
en politique, cela a plutôt bien fonctionné à plein
temps sur les questions de changement climatique, nous obtenons
environ 60% ou plus des voix,
alors je me précipite et serre la
main de m. chrétien parce qu'il avait été très  favorable
malgré son bon discours environnemental, l'
ouest du
canada était déterminé à développer ses
sables bitumineux l'industrie a dit bien nous donner une
certaine
certitude sur le prix que nous avons fait cela
et le ministre des ressources naturelles a
rassuré l'industrie pétrolière que les coûts de
kyoto resteraient minimes
et  le gouvernement s'assurerait
qu'un mois plus tard, la plus grande compagnie pétrolière du pays,
suncor, a
déclaré que ces coûts supplémentaires
ne représentaient que 20 à 27
ce  nts par baril de pétrole un prix qu'ils ont
dit être
négligeable c'est un problème critique
d'une grande importance cela pourrait bien entraîner
des pertes substantielles en vies humaines
donc je suis en colère quand cela est contrecarré par des
personnes qui ne recherchent qu'un
intérêt à très court terme de  l'expansion d'une
entreprise pendant
10 20 ou 30 ans
entre 1995 et 2004 la production de sables bitumineux
aurait plus que doublé
[Musique]
c'est une vue bucolique des bateaux entrant et
sortant de
vancouver mais ces navires sont souvent
chargés de pétrole
pour zipporah berman ce carburant est une clé
partie de la menace climatique
et elle a consacré sa vie à lutter
contre cela le
premier ministre harper avait fait un discours
au royaume-uni que je n'oublierai jamais où
il
nous venons tous de faire face au
changement climatique les sables bitumineux
sont le deuxième plus grand  dépôt de pétrole dans
le monde
sepura berman a quitté le canada pour diriger
le programme de changement climatique de greenpeace international
mais en 2012, inquiète de la
croissance massive des sables bitumineux,
elle a décidé de revenir au canada
tout le monde  commençait à réaliser à quel point
le changement climatique était grave
et le premier ministre harper s'est levé au royaume-
uni et a annoncé que le canada
allait devenir une superpuissance énergétique
en bref, c'est une entreprise aux proportions épiques
semblable à la construction des pyramides ou de la
grande muraille de chine seulement plus
grande  au début des années 2000, les sables bitumineux sont devenus
le lit noir
des écologistes et des célébrités
[Musique]
la pression n'a fait qu'augmenter après que
le gouvernement conservateur de stephen harper a
retiré le canada des accords de kyoto tout ce à quoi
je pouvais penser était le
canada et les débats qui se
déroulaient dans les sables bitumineux
travailler avec une petite équipe zepora berman a
tenté de faire ce que
personne en 25 ans n'a réussi à conclure un
accord avec l'industrie
pour limiter le développement des
sables bitumineux en alberta
elle l'avait fait avec l'
industrie forestière je vais leur demander de sortir
du  équipement,
vous devrez leur demander vous-même ces
personnes ne sont pas des criminels et elles
ne devraient pas aller en prison
les personnes qui devraient l'être  aller en prison en
ce moment détruisent la plaque avec le
son alors que nous nous tenons ici
j'ai été arrêté et accusé de 857
chefs d'accusation de complicité criminelle
et j'ai fait face à six ans de prison j'avais 23 ans.
finalement les deux parties ont convenu de rencontrer
le dialogue qui a suivi a
conduit  à un accord historique qui a
préservé une grande partie de la forêt tropicale de la Colombie-Britannique,
le contact a essayé de mettre berman en contact
avec des membres de l'industrie pétrolière
afin qu'elle puisse essayer de parvenir à un accord avec
eux une réunion a été organisée avec le
président
de leur association nous avions
vous savez vraiment certains  des conversations les plus
fascinantes que j'ai jamais eues
si vous êtes d'accord avec la science du climat,
que pensez-vous que notre juste part est ce que le
canada devrait faire d'
autres groupes environnementaux et les
cinq plus grandes sociétés pétrolières du canada ont
rapidement rejoint ces discussions ces
réunions secrètes
se sont déroulées principalement en privé
salles à manger pour les compagnies pétrolières l'
idée qu'ils me rencontreraient ainsi que d'
autres écologistes, vous savez qu'ils
étaient des traîtres
et cela  aurait été une
histoire explosive,
Imperial Oil est venu à certaines de ces premières
réunions, mais le dialogue avec eux
n'a pas duré à un moment donné, ils sont venus et ont
dit que
notre bureau américain, notre siège social, ne
nous laisserait pas poursuivre ces conversations
et ils ont dit que nous le ferions.  ne pas être
sur le point de pousser le gouvernement à
avoir une politique climatique plus forte
[Musique]
je ne sais pas je pense que nous aurions
pu faire un peu d'histoire
ce soir
l'élection d'un gouvernement ndp en
2015 en alberta
était une révolution politique et  le ndp
voulait s'attaquer aux discussions sur le changement climatique
qui ont commencé avec
le groupe de zipporah berman
ont été repris par le
gouvernement provincial et en novembre 2015 l'
alberta a conclu un accord historique pour
limiter le développement des sables bitumineux
la salle était électrique les gens pleuraient
je n'aurais jamais pensé voir
ça  le jour où
c'était c'était assez excitant c'est
le jour où
nous avons cessé de nier qu'il y a un problème
et c'est le jour où
nous faisons notre part en plus de fixer un
plafond sur greenhou  se émissions de gaz
quelque chose qui n'avait jamais été fait
avant l'accord
comprenait une taxe sur le carbone sur l'essence ainsi
que l'élimination progressive du charbon,
mais pour le riche kruger, le nouveau patron d'
imperial oil,
cela est allé trop loin, il s'est opposé à un plafond global des
émissions
et l'accord a créé un  schisme au sein de l'
industrie,
j'ai entendu dire qu'il y avait beaucoup de
réunions criantes du côté de l'industrie, mais je
suppose que compte tenu de la position d'exxon sur le
changement climatique à l'époque,
Imperial Oil ne serait pas en mesure
de rejoindre cette coalition
et ils avaient de grands plans d'expansion  cet
écart
que l'impériale a rejeté était très
généreux selon l'ancien
ministre de l'environnement david anderson,
par exemple, ils ont été autorisés à
émettre beaucoup plus d'émissions de pétrole
et de gaz
qu'ils n'en émettaient à ce moment-là
pour zipporah berman cet
accord
représentait une première étape, il n'était pas
suffisant
pour aligner le canada  émissions ou les
émissions de l'alberta avec des
périscopes, il n'était pas assez fort pour
limiter la production de t  il
sables bitumineux
mais c'était c'était une politique climatique forte une
politique forte peut-être mais le
gouvernement notley n'adopterait jamais de règles
mettant en œuvre un plafond d'émissions et pendant
la campagne électorale qui a suivi
l'accord et seppora berman elle
-même ont été
violemment attaquées l'alberta est ouvert aux
affaires
les conservateurs étaient  élu en 2019
et tout espoir d'action majeure sur le
changement climatique en alberta a
disparu les émissions de gaz à effet de serre ont
augmenté de près de 20 au canada depuis
et la production des sables bitumineux a augmenté
de 565 pour cent
entre 1992 et 2016.
bonjour à tous en octobre 2019 au
congrès américain  le comité a tenu des
audiences sur ce qu'il a appelé les efforts
de l'industrie pétrolière pour cacher la vérité
sur le changement climatique
ed garvey l'ancien scientifique d'exxon a
témoigné
merci pour l'opportunité de parler
devant le comité c'est un
message important
à savoir que les compagnies pétrolières étaient au courant
il y a des décennies que les dénégations et les
choses qui se sont
produites  ed puisque ce n'était pas le cas, alors les
gens
discutaient de la façon de traiter le
problème du changement climatique, pas de savoir
s'il existait ou non ou s'il était réel ou non
dans un e-mail, exxon nous a dit que les affirmations
concernant ses recherches sur le climat
sont inexactes et délibérément
trompeuses
.  des déclarations choisies attribuées à un
petit nombre d'employés
suggèrent à tort que des conclusions définitives
ont été atteintes il y a des décennies
coût du
changement climatique
exxon cite le juge dans l'affaire qui a
déclaré que les témoignages du procès ont
démontré qu'exxon a une culture d'
analyse disciplinée, de
planification, de comptabilité et de reporting
[musique]
mais environ 20 autres poursuites contre
exxon et d'autres sociétés pétrolières sont devant
les tribunaux des
municipalités comme charleston accusées
la société de tromper le public
sur les véritables dommages causés par leur
pro  conduit
ils se sont engagés dans une campagne intentionnelle
de tromperie
ils ont menti ils nous ont menti sur l'
impact
de leurs produits sur le changement climatique et
que cela conduirait
à une élévation du niveau de la mer
excellent a vraiment une énorme
entreprise c'était la plus grande entreprise au
monde alors
alors je  verraient que dans le cadre de leur
rôle de oui
pour guider l'industrie, ils étaient
assez grands pour pouvoir le faire s'ils avaient
choisi
george greene dit que l'impériale a eu une
grande influence sur le débat au canada
je pense qu'ils utilisent leur poids dans l'un
ou l'autre  bloquer ou changer le consensus
parmi leurs pairs,
c'est vraiment important et cela
affecte bien sûr le lobbying
et la vision du gouvernement
je blâme l'industrie
euh mais je blâme aussi le gouvernement de
ne pas
freiner euh ressources naturelles canada et d'
autres ministères
qui étaient essentiellement opposés  la
pensée des mesures de changement climatique n'est pas dans l'
intérêt de nos clients, donc nous ne sommes pas
intéressés non plus, l'
impériale nous a dit qu'elle soutenait  rts l'
accord de paris
et travaille avec les gouvernements pour
réduire les émissions au moindre
coût possible pour la société
grâce à d'importants investissements et à la recherche,
il dit qu'il a déjà réduit ses
émissions par baril de pétrole de 20
et il prévoit de les réduire de 10 autres d'
ici  2023
ce fut une année désastreuse pour exxon et
imperial oil
la crise du covid et la chute du
prix du pétrole ont
durement frappé l'entreprise mais finalement c'est
peut-être le marché lui
-même qui limite la croissance de l'entreprise dans les
sables bitumineux à l'époque je crois que
vous  sais que l'impériale pensait qu'il était
essentiel d'avoir un front uni contre
l'attaque de la politique climatique
euh je pense qu'ils ont perdu ce combat
toutes les grandes
banques disent que les sables bitumineux du canada seront l'
un des premiers pétroles à être retirés
du marché
parce que  c'est le carbone le plus élevé et le coût élevé il
n'y a pas si longtemps, exxon était la société la plus
appréciée sur le marché boursier d'
abord le vrai choc ici est une
compagnie pétrolière qui
sort et un nuage c  ompany
entrant en août 2020, il a été
expulsé de l'indice dow jones
pour catherine podvey il n'y a pas de temps à
perdre
[Music]
enquêter sur
vous étranger